I think he's totally conflicted because
as you know he wanted to be the FBI
director and I said no as you know I had
a business dispute with him after he
left the FBI we had a business did not a
nice one he wasn't he wasn't happy with
what I did and I don't blame him but I
had to do it because that's was the
right thing to do but I had a business
dispute and he loved swap over you look
at the relationship - done - so whether
it's love or deep like but he should he
was conflicted look Robert Muller should
have never been judged because he's on
the FBI job and he didn't get it and the
next day he would fix a special counsel
so you tell somebody I'm sorry you can't
have the job but then after you say that
he's going to make a ruling on you it
doesn't work that way
plus we had a business dispute plus his
relationship with Co me was
extraordinary that one other thing I'll
say why didn't we investigate strook and
pay the cave and Comey and all the lies
and Brennan in the lives and clapper and
the lies to Congress and all of the
things that happened to start this
investigation why didn't call me come
clean why didn't Comey come clean and
say the things that he knows are facts
widen Muller investigate combing his
best friend for his very good friends
and there's so many other things here's
a question
of Russia why didn't they invest the
insurance policy in other words should
Hillary Clinton lose we've got an
insurance policy guess what what we're
in right now is a totally conflicted
person I think balance is they choose
every jumper somebody's at this like
Donald Trump be somebody that didn't get
a job that are requested that he wanted
very badly and then he was appointed and
despite that despite 40 million dollars
18 drum painters including people that
work for Hillary Clinton and some of the
worst human beings on earth they got
nothing
it's pretty amazing